congratulations man welcome to Liberty
you know yeah I can't people why can't
people to say hey congratulations you're
living a half year more full life now
why can't you just do that to me and
said you gotta try to beat me up in the
street you gotta laugh at me got a point
at me saying you're your dude wearing a
dress you look ugly you're the ugliest
thing ever saying you should kill
yourself why are you doing that people
don't do that you're a man or a woman
you were born a man you can't be a woman
now who is it to you to judge that
you've never lived under water wells God
says your God to find something based on
2,000 year old book that you can't wear
cotton fibers with wool fibers or I
should stone you right now it's
ridiculous how they judge me it's based
on stuff that doesn't even make any
sense now there are so many things that
you can cut out of Leviticus it would
make our way of life in modern times
impossible by what you eat by what you
wear about what you save I want you to
buy all of it you couldn't live a life
in modern society based on Leviticus
2,000 year-old scriptures well no well
it's not really what God man well then
how can you share your pic and tell me
what God man are you God do you really
know what's going on are you the creator
when who you to judge what type of
people give you that sort of feedback do
you do you get that sort of feedback
with fellow veteran let's told I was
told I should kill myself just a week
ago based on sausage I had a veteran
write a whole bunch of stuff on a
Twitter post I have like all kinds of
stuff and I was like Heidi but ya know I
do your time out well you don't know me
I know you I was in your platoon you
said that Nana said you don't I was
covering up and I was underwater just
trying to be normal in your eyes I said
yeah if I said a lot of stupid stuff cuz
I was just trying to cover up and
survive in your world has it I'm finally
comfortable now and you're gonna give me
crap right my Twitter handle my facebook
handle my Instagram handle my Gmail
everything is the same valor for us
valor for us v for the number for VA lor
for us
is my media that's my social media I get
death threats I get hate me I'll get all
kinds of stuff I've been beaten up
two months ago I got freakin attacked
two months ago in a bar three months ago
now before the isolations go vid I had
someone attacked me in a bar where they
tried to beat me out did they know who
you were no no they just saw dude the
dress you're ugly you shouldn't even be
living and I was gone dude just let me
alone man and then he started talking
man yeah they they were on the floor
pretty quickly yeah I would imagine the
new he where they wouldn't have [ __ ]
with you know it just doesn't make sense
why don't you let me alone yeah it's sad
it's really sad I mean happy for me
speaking of Twitter did you didn't you
respond to Donald Trump when he tweeted
something about transgender people not
being should not be in the military so
that President President Trump tweeted
out that transgender people should not
be in a military in any capacity you
must get rid of us
that's about 15,000 people in uniform
today in uniform so he did our
transgender so basically you wanted to
kick out 15,000 people who nobody would
even know or some of them know but
they're doing a great job and the
problem was when he tweeted that the
army was under man by like 28% the
Marine Corps is under man but I like 15%
the Air Force was like 5% I think you're
doing pretty good but that but the
recruitment numbers to go to boot camp
and join the military we're all
significantly under undermanned so for
us the capability to fight a war on two
fronts if you had European war and
something going on in Asia or anything
going on we can't do it because we are
so undermanned because nobody wants to
join because it's a [ __ ] place to go
yeah and you want to kick out an
additional 15,000 people who are right
now serving and doing a good job because
of your prejudices it doesn't mean any
sense
that's why told my said hey look I
served 20 years I did a good job I
served with honor you never knew and it
didn't matter to you and who cares
you're gonna kick me out that's [ __ ]
let's talk to face-to-face let's talk
about this did you get any response
no no but about about six or seven
months later I met him face to face
shook his hand and I taught him has it
sir
served my country for 20 years I did a
good job a lot of people just like me
that want to serve and we want to serve
with honor and he said to me has he -
shaking my hand
thank you for service chief how'd he
know I was chief he knew you were yeah
they'll not make you how did that make
you feel well he just said thank of your
service chief you're welcome sir
just a lot of us I want to join and I'm
not gonna stop serving I served as day I
served in different capacities
I served by speaking to you maybe
dropping a couple of nuggets of truth
and having some people think a little
bit yeah have your mental toughness your
intellectual toughness your spiritual
toughness tell you what being a Muslim
America right now you have these fears
really tough but nobody cares but that
toughness they gonna cure how many
pushups you can do I welcome at 3
o'clock in the morning did a thousand
push-ups who cares man I know a guy
who's a Sikh like a Sikh elder the guy
is amazing you know who seeks are their
third like it religious like like
spiritual leaders man her tough and he's
a good friend of mine so I don't care
about a push-ups can do it three o'clock
in the morning I care about my really
good Sikh I'm awed mm-hmm I know another
one I'm in pushing and he was a seal and
he's frickin mentally tough he's way
tougher than doing a thousand push-ups
at 3:00 a.m. all above I have a really
good Muslim friend he was a Marine
Marine Corps and I got mentally tough
weight tougher than a thousand push-ups
at three o'clock in the morning I don't
care uh knee push-ups you at 3:00 about
good morning why don't you try being a
Muslim rain for a day it guys wait
tougher than you so a spiritual
toughness mental toughness intellectual
toughness freaking tough toughness not
what you do you wake up in the morning
and do push-ups
I don't care yeah that's weak that's a
weakest person ever sad because if all
you can do is do a thousand push-ups two
o'clock in the morning then you don't
yell and thump your chest about it I do
that thousand push
3:00 a.m. do you that's one of the
weakest people I've ever met
cuz you gotta yell about it you got to
tell everybody in the whole world how
many pushups you did I don't care
do it the house of push-ups don't tell
anybody about it that's tough don't care
you Yellin I don't care if you woke up
at 3:00 and wake up at 3:00 a.m. and do
whatever you gotta do
why do you got to tell anybody about it
the weakest person is one it does stuff
and yells and screams and thump stir
chest they brag about it and every turn
they brag girls are the weakest people
the tubs people do all the stuff and
nobody ever knew they did it I give
somebody a homeless man I'll give him a
$20 bill I'm not gonna tell anybody or
take a picture do anything and I'll do
that in a hundred times in a month
well [ __ ] I just said it yeah there's
gonna be some people in comments and you
just told all of us that's okay there's
so much stuff that happens just you
don't need to tell anybody about it just
do it man that's tough that's your
toughness you know who knows that you
did that you know who knows you did it
and who it counts it's you you just you
no one else not even a creator your
Creator doesn't care if you gave
somebody who needed some help somehow
people try to use bragging and saying
they've done great things as acts to
prop up something that's not there they
can get more followers yeah I don't have
followers cuz I don't I I try not to say
very much stuff about myself I I read a
lot of stuff on all my social media when
it did something incorrect I did
something without thinking I did
something that was callous or or or you
know in compassion I didn't I didn't
know what I was doing I mean I was like
darn it I did that wrong then I'll go
back and I try to fix it I try to make
it better and I try to do something good
where I failed so every time I fail I
try to do better I try to do something
those are the things that posed so I
don't have followers because I'm never
out there saying hey I just did a 23
mile run and
an hour and 20 minutes I just did this
where I did that I woke up at 3:00 a.m.
to a thousand push-ups I don't write any
nest off I write about stuff where I
screwed it up and then I try to do
better
mm-hmm so who's gonna follow me he
finally had followers I'm not gonna ever
have Fame I think you know followers
I try to defame myself and I try to make
it a lesson I try to give you some help
by saying what I did wrong or what I
felt bad about this or I wish I would've
done that better try to do lessons with
everything I do you know what I mean
it's important though because you do I
think I think you do have followers but
speaking to talking about the things
that you do wrong and the things that
you mess up I think that's important for
people to learn that and learn that it's
important to fail it's important to
think so like yeah you get a [ __ ] take
your sock off hey I did that didn't wake
myself I made a mask but I mean it's
just I just do stuff and I just try to
make it hey I learned something I don't
want you to know how to do this so maybe
you can do it I learned it from somebody
else and then I made a couple
improvements here and there and they're
like hey man my buddy Danny did
something with a sock before me and then
I said hey what if you do it like this
do it like that at something and then
hey man that's so all knowledge is like
borrowed and approved done at or done
that and then I give a lot of credit to
my friend Danny you know at better days
who came up with the first idea and it
was like man it's a great idea and I
want more people to know about it and so
now and you can even change us that you
put your chin where the foot is is
another way to do it or the heel goes
it'll it'll cuff in so I didn't improve
it someone else to improve what I did
and make it better cuz man all of life
is about improvements when the caveman
were here and they were you know
fighting at t-rexes they did a lot of
stuff and we've improved on it nothing's
new no everything's been said you just
had a different what do you think is the
biggest point of pain and fellow
veterans like yourself who have been in
combat as much as you have
and and how do you try to help them with
what you've experienced with trying to
let out bottled up emotions or bottled
up feelings and get them off your
shoulder like maybe that's one example
but what do you see is the biggest point
of pain or stress within people like
yourself who have dealt with what you've
dealt with well no you print this way if
you go to the Veterans Administration
and you see the number of people
registered and using the VA the VA
hospital and the doctors and
prescriptions and all the other stuff
and you look at the total number of
veterans in the United States the
percentage of people that use the VA is
like 20 percent of veterans so the other
80% are like hell no I'm not going to be
a you know why why are they at the VA
right I probably won't go to the VA
shortly cuz I'm just I'm angry because I
went to the VA and I was like hey man
I'm in a really tough spot right now and
I'm having some problems and I just need
help and I think and get I need help for
about six months or a year
I need a caregiver I need somebody
around to help me just mascara because I
had traumatic brain injury and and I had
some other stuff happened and I just I
need some help for a little while and
they have this thing called a caregiver
program
well they'll actually pay me a little
bit extra money so I can pay a caregiver
to come in and work with me for two or
three hours a day to make sure my
scheduling is good I'm on time I take my
medications I'm doing this I'm doing
that they're just like it's like a
checkup and I and I went to the VA and I
asked my said hey man I'm in a really
tough spot right now and you have this
caregiver program you're gonna give me
like 400 bucks a month or 800 bucks a
month so I could pay somebody could come
in like a qualified person that
understands scheduling and
pharmaceuticals and prescriptions all
the other stuff I'm doing because I'm
going to Tufts fire right now so I could
actually pay them to come in and be with
me for an hour or two hours every two or
three days or whatever come in once a
week I just go through my schedule go
through everything going on and make
sure everything's good you know make
sure I'll be eating healthy I'm not just
eating macaroni and cheese every day for
a month straight which I did and it
caused me to have this really win
cholesterol was off the charts I was
gonna McDonald's eat McDonald's eat mac
and cheese because I was just in that
real bad funk I was in a bad place so I
go to the VA and I go to this place I
had just caregiver program I'd say hey
I'm gonna apply for this caregiver
program and they asked me to all these
questions and and him let's see and I'm
I answered two questions like a seal
would I wasn't a winner lived in and I
have a limp and I go in there and I just
like and I tell them okay I mean I'm
doing okay I guess and I'm doing that in
a down time fighting winter and crying
and Gwinner lymph and I go in there
unshowered for a week which I did go for
about a week and a half and take a
shower
which because I was in a I was in a funk
and I couldn't get out and this is the
stuff that happens when you have you
know PTSD and traumatic brain injury
stuff doesn't always connect and so you
go for a week and a half without
showering didn't go out the house or
isn't and like you want to be socially
isolated what did it to myself a lot and
so I'm telling his caregiver program and
they deny me and I actually wouldn't I
asked him for help yeah because I knew
it was in a funk and I had stuff going
on and I needed some help and I want to
get out of the funk more I want it like
give me six months of this person to
come in once a week and help me out
that's what I was asking for I said I
want somebody for six months or a year
to come in for one or two days a week
for like two hours and just check
everything out and do that and do that
make sure I'm not in that [ __ ]
nothing's going on funky that I'm not
doing that and they said No
[Music]
[Laughter]